for people who don't understand
who aren't from la or don't understand
the politics of l.a why was it such a
huge deal that you sat down with jay
stone and did get an interview with him
uh because those that's two big rival
gangs like
[ __ ]
some of my homies can't even look at
them [ __ ] or talk to them or even
stand by them or stand 50 feet away from
them without being hysteric like
crazy going erratic you know i'm saying
like some of my [ __ ] can and some of
my [ __ ] can't like but
and vice versa like i can't go over
there you know what i'm saying like yeah
i could change my life i could do
whatever the [ __ ] i want to whatever but
at the end of the day i know where i'm
not wanting i can't be over there
because everybody ain't gonna feel like
me or him you know so but that was big
for the culture i felt like because even
though i think i don't know street [ __ ]
and we ain't changing [ __ ] lives and
you know
charity moving but it just shows you
like the growth
like we can all grow we can all speak
and talk to each other we can [ __ ]
around you know what i'm saying like
times times change bro we got kids we
got a family let's travel let's talk
let's joke let's have fun it's like all
the killing and [ __ ] like i just
it's nothing like you i don't i don't
agree with that [ __ ] no more man gang
banging is stupid you feel me like that
[ __ ] is outdated that [ __ ] is out of
here i mean isn't that really kind of
like the um
the root of the issue is that blood has
been spilled so yeah so when does it
stop because it's like
it's it's a non-stop cycle of like
one and like responding to bloodshed
with more bloodshed and i would always
ask my homies too and i'm like how does
that [ __ ] gonna stop
like if he killed him he killed him
it's just gonna keep going down the line
so how do it stop and they was like well
[ __ ] that's why you got to holler at the
kids because the older folks are already
stuck in this same this this frame of
mind so you try to go talk to the youth
and hopefully the youth will have a
different frame of mind
and then i'm like yeah i'm like that's
cool you can go speak to them but they
still got to go home
you know what i'm saying you still got
to go home where they where they're from
where are they from you know the mama
the daddy the auntie in the house they
still talking the crazy [ __ ] like and
then you'll just learn growing up you
feel me it's just learned mentality man
that [ __ ] is crazy so i don't really
know
how to [ __ ] that [ __ ] again
i mean i mean unless we just got a crazy
financial freedom and i don't yeah i
mean i remember like when nip passed and
um there was a like kind of like that
march that big you had uh organized i
know that was like a really big deal but
in terms of like
i don't know where do you feel because i
feel like in part man some of this
younger generation is more wider than
the older generation this younger
generation is on another level
and then on top of that they really
don't get they really not outside like
we were like it's a it's more so on the
internet there's some internet [ __ ]
but they are crazy because when they see
each other these things got big-ass ars
they shooting up [ __ ] shooting some call
of duty ass [ __ ] yeah they shooting up
parades and all type of [ __ ] like going
on like
so bruh it's crazy but
man i don't know man that [ __ ] is wild
man the younger generation compared to
us is just really wild but what big you
did do was special man for the for the
culture for sure like but not and i i
even asked him i'm like big you why the
[ __ ] you just can't go
get every [ __ ] from every set and say
you know what we ain't doing this no
more and if you [ __ ] is doing this
then we depend everybody are you gonna
keep doing this matter of fact you
[ __ ] can't be from the set no more
[ __ ] no more gaming and over you go
over there so why the [ __ ] y'all just
can't do that nigga's like [ __ ] it ain't
that easy
if it was that easy it's not that easy
but right it's you can do it you think
so it's doable if you brought [ __ ] to
the march i bet you there's a gang of
older og [ __ ] that feel the same way
like man i ain't trying to do this [ __ ]
no more and i ain't trying to see you
get killed you get killed you get killed
but i'm from this [ __ ] so majority
counts you feel me like majority rules
[ __ ] it we just gonna keep saying [ __ ]
it